thousands of tunisians protest
each feeling desperate and frustrated
this week their feelings have boiled
onto the streets
the coronavirus pandemic has crippled
their fragile economy
leaving a third of young tunisians
unemployed
they blame the government for their
problems
there is a feeling of deep
disappointment with the pandemic may god
protect us from it
poverty unemployment and the situation
we are living in as young people
now the protests have morphed to include
police brutality and unlawful
this detentions says more than 600
protesters have been arrested
most in their home and asks why
protesters are demanding their release
they say this is a government-ordered
crackdown
to the politicians i say one thing if
you have something to say
don't say it with the police go out to
the people and face them
the prime minister responded in a
televised address
i'm well aware that there is anger and
frustration in many areas
i know that the economic and social
situation is a crisis deepened by kovid
and the measures we have taken to
preserve the health of tunisians
your voice is heard and your anger is
legitimate
and it is my role and the governments to
work to realize your demands
and to make the dream of tunisia become
true
frustrations have rippled across
multiple tennessean cities this week
from the capital tunis south to sphaxx
and in the west here in kasserine the
rights group amnesty international has
warned against excessive use of force
yet at night protests have evolved into
running street battles between
demonstrators and police
the government has deployed the army in
several cities
and rolled out a curfew to quell the
clashes
the demonstrations come just days after
the 10-year anniversary
of the ouster of former president zain
al-abadine benali
a result of protests that birthed the
arab spring
but many tunisians feel disenchanted
saying the hope of that time
has gone unrealised
in 10 years there's no strategy or
prospects for the future
or even hope for change on the contrary
every year the amount of hope decreases
today in 2021 practically
all young people are just desperate
and so they turn to the streets for
answers just like they did a decade ago
charlotte palace al jazeera